didn't get your partner anything for
valentine's day how about writing them
out to the feds the bureau of alcohol
tobacco firearms and explosives posting
this image in a tweet
giving disgruntled people a tip line
they can use to turn in their current or
former lovers do you have information
about a former or current partner
involved in illegal gun activity let us
know and we will make sure
it's a valentine's day to remember
jesse i feel compelled to start with you
why um as you you think about this is
this is this something that that you
would you know someone that loves big
government is this something that you
would think government should be a part
of personally do you think you're gonna
get narcs hi uh atf this is erica my ex
dante uh yeah he's dating melissa now my
best friend um yeah he always talked
about having ghost guns in the house he
lives at 141 washington why don't you go
kick down the door tell him melissa
is there i mean that's what you're gonna
get i like the phone that you're using
yeah nobody nobody under
how do you do it craig how do you do it
i'm like this hey how do you just stick
to that how do you how do you make a
phone call i am with the kids man the
kids know him
speaker
speakerphone all the way
do you know what i used to do when i was
d.a i'm afraid
i used to we used to send out
notes to people saying they want a prize
and show up at a particular place and
then i'd have them all arrested because
we had warrants out on them i remember
those things that worked yeah they made
a vacation or a winnebago and they'd
show up and they'd be all like that
they'd be under arrest
jesse jesse we're laughing but jesse
raised the point i did how people could
look it's up to them is that is that
illegal it's not illegal it's up to the
police to decide whether the claim that
they're getting and the report that
they're getting is sufficient for them
to make an arrest or to open up a file
that's all i think it's a planning a bad
idea with angry weird people it is not
it's planned like wait a minute greg's
home in his basement he's armed to the
hilt and then hang up yeah but wait a
minute they're not gonna go to your
basement first of all what about hunter
biden's girlfriend throwing a gun in the
garbage pail because if somebody said
that's not his girlfriend threw a gun in
the garbage pail you want to say no i'm
not going to look in dana dana what are
your thoughts on this i just think that
you don't have to tweet every day that
there's a holiday you have to talk about
every holiday if you're the atf you
don't always have to put out a statement
about everything i would rather have
tougher judges and more jails in some
mental institutions rather than this
yeah i just want to see what they're
going to put out on easter yeah
[Music]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else